qui
bonjour bernier leur génération europe
nous sommes ici à la cité internationale
universitaire au collège franco
britannique l'europe à l'étranger en
quoi est elle utile c'est de cela dont
nous allons parler avec les étudiants
européens et avec notre invité
aujourd'hui celle écologiste yannick
jadot
bonjour à tous alors le fait de parler
rien de parler de la place de l'europe
dans le monde aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est un sens tout particulier quand on
pense qu'on est en 2014 et qu'on est
juste cent ans après le début de la
première guerre mondiale c'est le
centenaire jules bah ouais s'entend
après la grande boucherie qui a été la
première guerre mondiale ça a un sens de
parler de l'union des peuples européens
je pense mais en revanche c'est un sens
d'en parler mais actuellement l'union
européenne la question c'est est ce
qu'elle est une action en faveur de la
paix avec ses draps moi je ne pense pas
malgré les huit bonnes déclarait les
grandes déclarations etc elle mène une
politique de en faveur de la guerre
économique en fait finalement entre les
peuples parce que c'est ça le libre
échange c'est la guerre économique entre
les peuples et donc oui c'est un sens à
des dates en parler aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit je trouve que justement l'objet de
l'union européenne cédait 2 un
développement économique ensemble au
sein de l'europe et je trouve qu'à nous
avons vraiment réussi à faire ça je tue
pas dans quel sens il ya une guerre
économique entre les jeunes et belles
c'est juste un exemple en 2012 quand la
ligne l'apn a reçu le prix c'est un
exemple du succès qu'on a qu'on a
atteint il n'y a pas un seul un seul
continent qui a réussi à atteindre une
telle un tel objectif on est un vrai
continent pacifique c'est intéressant tu
dis que l'objectif de paix menés par
l'union européenne n'est pas atteint
parce qu'aujourd'hui on mène encore une
guerre qui est économique c'est vrai
mais au moins l'inquiétude que nous on
peut avoir aujourd'hui entre 20 et 25
ans c'est pas de finir dans une tranchée
avec un fusil à la main c'est de finir
au chômage non mais c'est intéressant
l'évolution est ce qu'il existe toujours
alors je voudrais que on aille voir un
petit peu les fondamentaux du sujet on a
parlé de l'économie qu'inapte tous les
sujets qu'on aborde veut quand on parle
de l'europe forcément vrai qu'on regarde
la mécanique et les outils que possède
l'union européenne en matière de défense
de diplomatie on regarde c'est un sujet
de thierry scharff mise en image par
hugo nicolas et c'est l'essentiel une
chose est sûre la faiblesse de l'union
européenne sur la scène internationale
n'est pas en rapport avec sa place de
première puissance économique mondiale
et pourtant l'europe s'est dotée depuis
le traité de lisbonne en 2009 d'une
politique européenne de sécurité et de
défense la psb avec deux innovations la
nomination d'un haut représentant aux
affaires étrangères et à la politique de
sécurité une sorte de ministre des
affaires étrangères light c'est la
britannique catherine ashton qui occupe
actuellement le poste est le service
européen pour l'action extérieure dont
le siège est à bruxelles et qui détient
un réseau de 130 9 délégations dans le
monde l'action extérieure de l'europe
s'appuie sur des valeurs communes telles
que la démocratie la paix et droits de
l'homme la coopération multilatérale ou
le droit international
en pratique les états membres réunis en
conseil à définir des positions communes
par exemple la non prolifération
nucléaire et met en oeuvre des actions
communes nomination de représentants
spéciaux programme de déminage est aussi
en voie de force militaire ou civil 27
opérations civiles ou militaires ont été
lancés sur trois continents des poils
aux familles nomme 14 sont en cours
comment ma vie en afghanistan ou au
large des côtes somaliennes où l'europe
cette loi à lutter contre la piraterie
l'europe est aussi capable d'embargo ou
de sanctions économiques par exemple au
régime syrien ou biélorusse question
financement en 2013 l'action extérieure
européenne aura coûté 9,4 milliards
d'euros soit 6,4 pour cent du budget
total européen dérisoire si on le
compare au sol budget français de
défense de 31,4 milliards
il ya donc aujourd'hui 14 opérations
civilo militaire en cours comme au mali
en afghanistan est ce que quand il ya
des crises dans le monde james par
exemple tu as l'impression sur ces dix
dernières années que l'europe a joué son
rôle en matière de diplomatie ou de
défense je ne sais pas s'il ya un rôle
pro l'europe tant la défense l'action
est range à
l'action militaire dans le monde pour
moi c'est le cas de la souveraineté des
états et on ne peut pas confier ce rôle
à l'union européenne
pourquoi c'est pas le sort de l'union
européenne pour moi et pour les anglais
c'est un projet économique d'intégration
économique pourquoi faut-il l'étranger
c'est pas réaliste comme position de
vouloir garder au niveau de la
souveraineté des états ses compétences
là parce que bon c'est toujours on va
dire que c'est toujours le même argument
qui revient mais ce que représente la
population de l'union européenne au
niveau mondial c'est 5% la population de
l'union européenne pas de la france si
on prend le poids économique dans dix
ans il y aura plus aucun état européen
dans le top 10 des économies une date
comment peut-on avoir une légitimité sur
le plan diplomatique
sur le plan de la défense si on a pas on
ne rassemble pas les force à un niveau
européen et pourtant je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets sur lesquels comme on
l'a vu dans le reportage les droits de
l'homme la démocratie même l'écologie ou
l'union européenne partagent des valeurs
communes qu'elle peut porter sur un plan
international donc pour moi c'est une
nécessité qu' il ya un rassemblement des
forces européennes sur le la diplomatie
on touche au coeur justement de cette
question est ce qu'on arrive à avoir une
centralisation une europe qui peut
penser la diplomatie extérieure
ensemble on va faire tout de suite
rentré notre invité qui va nous éclairer
nous apporter son point de vue bonjour
yannick jadot bonjour
vous êtes député européen écologiste
depuis 2009 vous êtes vice président de
la commission du commerce international
et coordinateur pour le groupe des verts
alors on voulait parler surtout
diplomatie et surtout par les défenses
et finalement on parle de la guerre qui
existent aujourd'hui qui est celle
économique forcément on est obligé de de
glisser sur ce terrain là quand on parle
du rapport de l'europe au reste du monde
je crois en tout cas c'est pas on peut
pas les dissocier parce que c'est vrai
que
l'europe globalement et une position
hégémonique sur le monde pendant quatre
siècles et puis on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la globalisation elle a
changé qui a des pays émergents qui
viennent contester notre hégémonie et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que de plus en plus
dans nos sociétés nous payons un certain
coût de la mondialisation avant c'était
simplement à notre profit donc on
s'enrichit c'est sur les ressources
naturelles du reste du monde bon
maintenant aujourd'hui on paie une
partie des coûts de la mondialisation et
que ça affole beaucoup nos sociétés et
nos opinions publiques donc et puis à
partir du moment où il ya eu la fin la
chute du mur de berlin la fin de
l'affrontement est ouest qui était un
affrontement essentiellement sur le sol
européen eh ben on a eu l'impression que
finalement la diplomatie a laissé la
place à une mondialisation économique à
une mondialisation libérale qui s'est
substitué jir très largement à la
diplomatie la diplomatie européenne un
positionnement aujourd'hui on lui
reproche par exemple ne pas avoir vu
arriver le printemps arabe est de ne pas
avoir eu un positionnement européen
quelle est votre lecture c'est vrai que
en tout cas elle est largement
insuffisante elle est largement
insuffisante à mon avis pour deux
raisons c'est pas facile de se mettre
d'accord à 28 par rapport à la russie on
voit bien que la relation de la pologne
et des pays baltes à la russie peut pas
être la même que celle du portugal ou de
l'espagne donc évidemment à se mettre
d'accord et donc à trouver un consensus
et puis la réalité c'est vrai que les
états au niveau des états nations ont
abandonné beaucoup de souveraineté aux
marchés et donc ils font vivre
médiatiquement il essaye de faire vivre
dans leur pays l'idée que les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ce sont encore
des grands chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui décide de tout quelle
est la puissance aujourd'hui même d'un
pays comme la france face à la
spéculation financière internationale il
est très faible on voit bien que la
france face à un acteur comme monsieur
mittal est très faible face au climat on
est très faible face à la chine on est
très faible si on est isolé voyez bien
comment se construit la politique
c'était qu'on a une grande messe
présidentielle tous les cinq ans où on
nous explique que le président dans les
frontières de l'état nation va nous
sortir d'une crise forcément mondialisé
et donc
plus les états ont perdu de pouvoir et
plus finalement ils essayent de faire
croire que sur la scène internationale
ils sont puissants l'un d'entre vous
disais c'est vrai que dans dix quinze
ans il y aura plus d'états européens au
sein du g8 c'est vrai qu'on voit notre
difficulté à peser sur les affaires du
monde et donc à la fois cette résistance
à avoir une politique commune de défense
une diplomatie commune ce qui est
parfois totalement aberrant à ce qu'il
faut avoir 25 27 ambassade en malaisie
puis on peut quand même sérieusement
s'interroger alors on va donner la
parole à lorraine je trouve que vous
avez entièrement raison c'est notre seul
moyen en fait de faire un poids de nous
affirmer sur la chaîne internationale
surtout quand finalement nous les aurons
pas seulement bien quoi pas besoin de
nous unir de mutualiser nos moyens en
terme par exemple faire des trucs très
concrets les ambassades et certaines
ambassades et jacky ont été créés des
franco allemande à certains endroits
donc c'est un premier pas mais en plus
on bénéficie d'un rôle on a toujours été
vu comme les médiateurs enfin surtout
depuis la manière dont on a résolu la
seconde guerre mondiale dans certains
continents en asie ils sont demandeurs
de nos conseils eux qui sont en proie à
des ddd violents conflits médiateur je
trouve que c'est une notion extrêmement
intéressante parce que c'est avec je
disais tout et par l'europe a été une
puissance hégémonique très forte c'est
la première puissance commerciale du
monde c'est surtout un nain politique et
que typiquement nommé la façon dont par
exemple la france et la grande-bretagne
s'accroche au poste au conseil de
sécurité notre siège au conseil de
sécurité et ne met pas l'europe ne
remplace pas
la france la grande-bretagne par
l'europe pour changer notre mode de
régulation au conseil de sécurité oui
c'est ça montre que la notre frilosité à
passer à une étape supérieure est ce que
c'est le sens qui s'imposent forcément à
ce que vous avez l'impression qu'à une
frilosité alors james toi tu penses que
c'est très bien comme ça l'union
européenne elle est économique et c'est
la base et ça suffit est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya un besoin
finalement de pratiquer cette bascule
des pouvoirs oui bien sûr par exemple
vous parler de cette
volonté de garder le poste de sécurité à
moi à mon avis ça vient quand même de la
peur de la peur d'une chute de ceux de
ce grand organisme qui peut être l'union
européenne donc là là c'est vraiment le
fait que les étangs en réalité cherche
quand même toujours à se défendre même
de dans l'union européenne ne pourquoi
parce que ces expressions de la crise
économique mais peut-être que justement
puisqu'on revient toujours à la question
économique qu'elle est induite par tous
est ce que la crise économique n'a pas
aussi bousculer les mentalités qu'est ce
que t'en pense que oui dit-il fait que
du coup il ya des prises de conscience
ça fait pas très longtemps réalité qu'on
se pose la question de la diplomatie
européenne à l'international ou de la
défense tout ça a été mis en place sur
les cinq dix dernières années vraiment
alors que l'europe existe depuis 60
normalement c'est que depuis 2009 mais à
mon avis le le débat d'une de la place
de l'europe dans le monde il est
beaucoup plus large que juste la
politique extérieure de l'europe vous
parliez de du droit de veto au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu je pense que là
c'est quelque chose on est sur un point
vraiment centrale parce que il s'agit de
savoir quelle architecture politique on
veut au 21e siècle c'est à dire que on
est la mondialisation nous a fait
prendre conscience qu'il ya un certain
nombre de problèmes qui peuvent être
résolus que à l'échelle internationale
et les problèmes de l'environnement les
problèmes de gestion des ressources non
renouvelables etc et là dessus je pense
que l'europe un rôle qui fondamental à
jouer parce que il s'agit pas seulement
de protéger des intérêts des pays il
s'agit de d'exporter un modèle
d'affirmer des valeurs qui sont celles
du national et on a tous des egos et ça
en gros on n'a pas tous des ego c'est
que encore une fois le jeu politique et
médiatique il se construit les chaînes
nationales donc un chef détails de
gouvernement doivent faire croire qu'il
a beaucoup de pouvoirs mais ça va
changer ça doit ça doit changer ça doit
absolument changer vous savez les
réunions du g8 et du g20
regardez tous ceux qui tous les chefs
d'état sortant nous disent ça en fait ça
ne sert à rien c'est une grande messe on
se voit on fait des photos le président
français s'affiche à côté du président
américain tout ça donne l'impression du
pouvoir mais n'est pas la réalité du
pouvoir et quand on voit notre relation
de l'europe par rapport à la chine au
par rapport à la russie on voit bien que
ces pays arrive totalement à nous
diviser la chine quand elles se baladent
en europe quand le président chinois ou
le prémunit sua se baladent en europe
ils viennent pas voir les institutions
européennes il joue chaque état membre
les uns contre les autres les russes
font exactement la même chose ils font
du chantage des investissements ici du
chantage là ce qui fait qu'on n'arrive
pas à avoir de politique commune
vis-à-vis de ces pays là et donc on
n'arrive pas se manipule sur la question
du dumping social sur la question des
droits de l'homme sur la question du
dumping environnemental du dumping
fiscal ou du dumping monétaire on
n'arrive pas à poser et ça c'est une
vraie difficulté est d'ailleurs regardez
ce qui représente l'europe du point de
vue diplomatique
lady ashton à la com été choisie parce
qu'elle ne fait donc pas personne donc
en permanence on met au niveau européen
non pas des jacques delors on met au
niveau européen des gens qui ne vont pas
faire bon bon alors je vous propose
maintenant d'évoquer le fait que l'union
européenne mène une action humanitaire
sans égal au point qu'on dit d'ailleurs
d'elle que c'est la plus grande ong du
monde lorraine tu es allé enquêter là
dessus tu as été notre tin tin notre
reporter de 10 mois comment tu vécu
cette expérience c'était très
intéressant je savais que l'union jouait
déjà un rôle important en terme de dead
de développement humanitaire mais là en
allant rencontrer ces gens là je me suis
rendu compte que vraiment c'est est
centrale dans le raid pour le coup ça
fait plaisir de faire partie de l'union
européenne écoutez
le reportage de lorraine guidé par
thierry scharff
lorraine 22 ans se verrait bien
diplomate un métier tout privé pour cet
europhile fervente né aux pays bas et
qui a fait ses études en partie en
angleterre et journaliste celui ray bien
aussi
ministère des affaires étrangères et
pourtant il ya un domaine dans lequel
elle est hyper présente c'est
l'humanitaire pourquoi enquête
et c'est parti pour la première
interview en duplex de bruxelles
attention bonjour tout le monde est prêt
et je suis pris 1,81
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer que
l'europe accorde autant d'importance l
aide humanitaire et surtout finançable
alors l'union européenne et
l'organisation dans le monde qui donne
le plus d'être développement en 2012
c'est plus de 50 milliards d'euros dont
énormément d'argent que l'union
européenne a pu investir pour lutter
contre la pauvreté dans les pays les
plus les plus atteints par la pauvreté
extrême pour donner une source de
comparaison c'est deux fois plus que les
états unis pour la même année
mais alors qui a dit que les européens
n'avaient pas un sacré coeur
parmi les nombreuses ong qui bénéficient
des aides européennes
lo ng française agronomes et
vétérinaires sans frontières
engagé dans le programme agir sahel un
programme de développement destiné à
venir en aide aux populations de cette
région africaine touchée notamment par
la question des sécheresses
aujourd'hui dans le budget global
d'agronomes et vétérinaires sans
frontières le financement européen
représente 40% du budget dont vous voyez
c'est un financement essentiel c'est le
premier contributeur
donc finalement sans l'aide européenne
aucun de ces projets n'existerait donc
sans l'europe pas de projets
mais comment expliquer l'extrême généré
c'est l'union européenne j'ai rendez
vous avec rony brauman qui est pour moi
la référence en la matière
la raison pour laquelle l'europe est
extrêmement
engagée dans l'humanitaire c'est parce
qu'elle n'a pas de politique étrangère
commune c'est parce que les désaccords
entre les différentes nations qui la
composent sont telles qu'il n'y a pas de
synthèse possible mais on peut tout de
même se réjouir que
poule aussi important que l'europe
apporte des ressources à une action qui
tout de même mérite d'être soutenue doit
être soutenue aussi bien par des
particuliers que par des entités
politiques
la générosité comme lot de consolation
plus humanitaire par défaut pas
seulement
une dernière étude con con qu'on a fait
un par exemple montrer que notre aide au
développement dans les sept prochaines
années sera complètement
remboursé si je veux par le nombre de
d'investissement de point de croissance
qu'elle ramène en afrique autant qu en
europe donc ce que je veux dire on est
là pour sauver les vies mais c'est aussi
dans notre intérêt en termes par exemple
de croissance économique
a finalement on n'est pas totalement
généreux purement généreux gilles ta
réaction moi je vois là une
contradiction majeure qui est montré
dans ce sujet là par exemple on voit des
initiatives des projets qui sont
développés au sahel etc l'union
européenne d'une main elle va donner et
de l'autre à martres on en fait parce
que les accords économiques qui sont
passés qui empêche les pays africains de
subventionner leur agriculture par
exemple avec ce sont des échanges n'ont
alors que nous on subventionne notre
agriculture par le biais par le biais de
la politique agricole commune et sinon
une ong juste un autre exemple est une
autre contradiction qui me semble
vraiment c'est un cas édifiant c'est la
palestine
union européenne donne régulièrement des
millions d'euros d'argent public pour
développer des infrastructures en
palestine notamment dans la bande de
gaza en 2009 lui l'opération plomb durci
toutes les infrastructures construites
par l'union européenne ont été détruites
alors d'un côté on donne notre côté on
prend jamais une seule sanction contre
l'état israélien alors qui viole le
droit international constamment à bien
le biais de la colonisation et ses
deuxièmes deuxième chose juste on ne
s'entraîne pas on pourrait avoir par
exemple
juste laisse-moi finiront pour avoir une
politique de sanctions économiques
contre les entreprises européennes qui
collabore à la colonisation moi j'en
vois plusieurs choix orange orange
participe à la colonisation theolia
éolien je maintiens ce n'est pas la
colonisation et bouygues bâtiment
participe à la colonisation on ne les
sanctionne pas et c'est le même cas pour
areva au niger par exemple si je peux me
permettre tout ce qui est dit là est
vrai la question c'est est ce qu'il ya
un endroit où se construit une telle
perversité non c'est à dire que moi j'ai
travaillé pour l'union européenne au
bangladesh dont on soutenait d'énormes
projets des ong
sur la lutte contre la pauvreté
notamment pour les en faveur des femmes
mais c'est vrai que une bonne partie des
relations des états membres lui européen
au bangladesh ne remettait pas en cause
la corruption du gouvernement bangladais
ce que j'ai aimé ça veut pas forcément
dire qu'à un moment on est simplement
cynique en dix ans là on va aider parce
que c'est sympa là on est cynique parce
qu'on les empêche de se développer et la
sensation de la cohérence la question de
la cohérence et des valeurs mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que dans la même
façon dans l'administration en france ou
du point de vue politique ou dans notre
fonctionnement parfois puis on est aussi
pétri de contradictions moi je me bats
au niveau de la commission du commerce
international sur tous les enjeux que
vous avez mentionné y compris faut
savoir quand même que l'union européenne
met en place aujourd'hui des
vérifications très stricte sur les
produits qui viennent des colonies pour
ce qui concerne la palestine donc il ya
des instruments mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
un rapport de force politique qui est
très compliquée à mettre en oeuvre ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya pas il
n'ya pas le con clos et il n'ya pas
l'extrême générosité l'union européenne
n'atteint pas les objectifs fixés par
les nations unies en matière d' aide
donc elle n'est pas généreuse il ya du
retour mais c'est le grand bailleur
c'est monde mais c'est le plus grand
bailleur et un certain nombre de ces
projets sont extrêmement pertinent et je
vous propose maintenant de regarder la
question de notre partenaire technikart
olivier malnuit on y répond juste après
la puissance douce cette politique
étrangère européenne basée sur l'absence
de conflits en fait et plus sur un
système de pressions amicales ou une
amicale on est vraiment en droit de se
demander si au fond ça marche tant que
ça
puisque on se rend compte que lorsqu'il
ya urgence lorsqu'il ya une crise à
régler seuls quelques états
interviennent souvent de façon isolée
comme ça a été le cas récemment de la
france donc le ma question c'est la soft
power est ce que c'est vraiment efficace
c'est vraiment efficace selon toi est-ce
que c'est là dessus finalement qu'il
faut s'engager oui je trouve que c'est
ça pourrait être efficace dans les
domaines où l'union européenne devaient
agir donc tout ce qu'il s'agit de
conclure des accords économiques fabi
sanctions économiques c'est bien et je
pense que ça d action unifiée plus
fortes comme l'intervention militaire je
trouve que c'est pas dans le sort de
l'union européenne
le problème c'est que après la chute de
l'urss le temps est elle toujours été là
pour défendre l'europe problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le temps qui est dirigée
par les états unis il se barre en asie
donc maintenant c'est aux européens de
reprendre leurs responsabilités et on
est tout seul finalement donc il faut
tirer vraiment la sellette d'ailleurs
les européens doivent malheureusement
peut-être se mettre à créer une
politique de défense commune parce que
sinon on va être complètement tout seul
et même si les anglais sont pas d'accord
il ya forcément des moyens pour faire ça
pour s'arranger sans eux sans dec
à l'origine il était tombé nationale qui
refuse la politique européenne de
défense c'est pas la grande bretagne à
l'origine dans les années 110 c'est la
france qui refuse d'appliquer que les
français sont prêts à se placer en
leader grâce à la structure c'est ça le
problème c'est que la france est
toujours prête à faire quelque chose
c'est les leaders elle est toujours
prête à faire un pas vers l'europe si
l'europe ressemble à la france ça peut
pas fonctionner comme ça et les bulgares
alors se sont jamais leader sans jamais
leader mais je pense qu'il ya un leader
européen et c'est clair que c'est
l'allemagne c'est un madame angela
merkel qui a tout cas vous le crès cette
idée d'une europe comme une petite comme
la petite suisse qui est la sorte par
heure mais que c'est un modèle qui c'est
c'est évident que ça marche très mal et
que finalement l'europe se tourne
toujours vers les états unis donc je
pense pas qu'on est seul au sens pour la
défense nationale manches coupées si
vous voulez l'histoire de l'allemagne
fait que la perspective de d'intervenir
de manière militaire dans le monde reste
un problème allemand à table mais un
tabou oui enfin ça reste extrêmement
compliqué mais va falloir revenir y
compris en matière d'efficacité on voit
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe on a vu ce que
ça donnait en libye on n'arrive pas à
projeter une intervention militaire sans
le soutien des états unis c'est pas
possible alors qu'on dépense des
centaines de milliards d'euros pour les
dépenses militaires en europe mais comme
on dépense chacun dans notre coin on
n'arrive pas à créer les économies d'où
la nécessité de mutualiser la même façon
on doit voir autour de 1,5 2 million de
soldats en europe on a un pet
150000 qui sont capables d'intervenir
dans le monde mais comme ça j'ai du jh
est en réalité le budget est très faible
parce que quand on regarde bien manger
mais il ajouté oui que je veux dire
c'est que si vous avez été choisi mais
c'est beaucoup mais on n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui trouver les modalités il
faudrait un budget centralisée quand on
va tenter une entrée
l'action extérieure européenne aura
coûté au moins 10 milliards d'euros soit
fière de ce qu'on fait parce qu'on n'a
pas d'armée parce qu'on n'a pas d'armée
européenne moi je crois que ça se
tissent ça sans visage ça se construit
il faut se re définir si on a eu un faux
pas ou si on veut avoir une politique
étrangère européenne forte il faut à un
moment donné et en capacité d'intervenir
donc je crois qu'il faut une armée mais
la question de l'intervention européenne
doit se faire notamment
en guise au mandat des nations unies que
peut-être le premier corps qu'il
faudrait créer c'est des gens qui font
de la prévention et d'intervention
militaire ce qu'on appelle
d'intervention civile en fait quand on
parle de la centrafrique
on l'a vue venir quand même ça fait des
mois et des mois qu'on sait qu'on a
convergent à la catastrophe humanitaire
si on s y en avait des vrais corps
européen de militaires européens qui
commencerait par intervenir pour les
missions des nations unies l'émission
paix des nations unies ça serait pour
nous progressivement aller vers une
forme de mutualisation et d'une plus
grande cohérence de nos interventions et
moi j'ai une question à ce qu'on voit là
en fait vu le manque de démocratie
actuellement dans l'union européenne
quand il s'agit de décider des
politiques économiques et c'est la juste
on va signer avec les états unis par
exemple un grand marché transatlantique
ou l'époque ne seront pas consulté qui
décidera de ces politiques là quand on a
ruiné rami européenne est ce que c'est
le pari d'un comédien qui va décider on
sait qu'actuellement ondes et les
européens ne peuvent pas décider et je
me bats je me bats tous les jours au
sein la commission du commerce
international parlement européen
justement pour je m'occupe de ce sujet
du traité transatlantique époque et de
la démocratie
c'est propre c'est absolument scandaleux
on entre à négocier des choix de société
sur notre alimentation sur nos services
publics et les citoyens sont exclus ils
peuvent même pas consulté les documents
mais là à la fois on a besoin d'europe
il faut dissocier je suis d'accord sur
le fait qu'aujourd'hui une bonne partie
des décisions ne sont pas démocratiques
parce qu'elles sont prises par les
gouvernements ne nous trompons pas c'est
pas parce que la commission est une
technocratie insupportable elle est
parfois mais c'est parce que des
gouvernement décide si les citoyens
européens ne veulent plus de politiques
d'austérité ou ne veulent une diplomatie
plus forte il faut qu'ils l'expriment
dans les urnes si vous avez des
politiques néolibérales en europe
aujourd'hui c'est parce que les citoyens
européens ont majoritairement voté pour
des gouvernements mais aux libéraux une
majorité au parlement européen qui est
plutôt libérale donc c'est aussi aux
citoyens à ne pas faire de l'europe une
sorte de fantasme d'idéologie l'europe
est un espace politique c'est un espace
politique si on s'en empare on en fait
ce qu'on veut si on le laisse aux autres
et bien c'est les autres qui d'ici
d'ailleurs vous voulez en train
dissidence oui absolument on arrive à la
fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup je rappelle la sortie de
votre livre il ya quelques semaines aux
éditions plon entrons en dissidence
merci à chacun d'entre vous on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour parler
d'un nouveau thème de génération europe
et en l'occurrence ce sera au tour des
frontières de l'europe comment les
dessine ton que ce sont les limites au
mois prochain à trith
oui